good morning John so for the first event
a long time I don't have anything like
super pressing to make a video about
today I mean I got ideas got plenty of
ideas but instead of doing one of those
things I decided to turn this video over
to the nerdfighters of Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr and Reddit to decide
for me what I would do in this video
pretend to be a crab okay spider-man
Donald Glover all the way show us lemon
and herder penis talk about throwing
paper balls near cats and their
subsequent reactions sianis cat is the
domesticated house cat interests include
meat pate warm things and strings the
couch considers the paper ball to be a
little bit like a massive moose and
skitters and makes noises like a mice
but it is not juicy like am i struggling
nerdy Valentine's Day jokes I could
never break up with my girly girlfriend
she's a keeper I have a friend who
married a librarian instead of giving
him a ring at the wedding ceremony she
just stamped it not for circulation
yeah no moving on can you tell us
everything about your book yeah I'm
thinking about writing a fiction II
thing right now it's about a girl and a
robot and what it means to be human
please play mine good this is the nerd
craft area minecraft server which is
always beautiful but is right now
decorated for Valentine's Day isn't it
adorable
Donna speedo cover self in peanut butter
bacon mixture talk about Gundam no no TV
recommendations please agent Carter
agent Carter a jacquard a jacquard
Andrew asks what are some of your
favorite things that likely very few
people have heard of the animated series
cudoce lock and key comics paolo becae
gallupi the creations of neil sega
serega the board game Roboto ricochet
and let's go with the third pew show us
your lunch five guys they have free
peanuts but I have to have my hamburgers
on hot dog buns because I can't eat
sesame seeds make video explaining the
Keystone XL pipeline okay
ah the Keystone XL is an extension of
the current Keystone pipeline it would
go all the way from Alberta to Louisiana
which is a long way the idea being we
could get all the oil from the tar sands
down to the ports there where we could
ship it all over the world
think this is a bad idea the biggest
reason is that the tar sands are the
second biggest sink of carbon in the
world and they're a super inefficient
source of oil it takes a lot of energy
and thus produces a lot of carbon
dioxide just to turn it into a usable
product so you're creating a ton of
carbon dioxide even before you burn the
oil tar sands what we call
unconventional oil and ideally we will
leave all of the unconventional oil in
the ground because once we start burning
the unconventional oil there is so much
of it there's just so much and it that's
just game over for climate change try
spinning a staph baton sword stick
draw my line okay we've not done that
yet I'm Hank green I live in Montana
where I take up a trivial amount of
space Montana on the other hand is a
fairly small percentage of the earth the
earth meanwhile is a truly miniscule
amount of space in the solar system
which is likewise basically
insignificant compared to the size of
our galaxy which once again is
completely trivial compared to the size
of the known universe my life will take
place during an amount of time that is
on a universal scale not just
insignificant but unnoticeable my life I
drew it make a cover song or a parody
cuz it's on up on my head part when
maybe just the front being the owner of
it ain't hard can't think of one I'd
rather one have until it's pretty
awesome better than a bottle of
champagne
I got a hank face baby and I'll write
your name on on my face I won't actually
do that though okay I think that's good
it's probably gonna be about four
minutes I'm guessing but I've been doing
this for a while so I'm probably spot-on
we'll see John I'll see you on Tuesday